IRFAN DAMA: Good afternoon
ladies and gentlemen.
As we say in India, [HINDI],
brothers and sisters.
It's so good to be here
with such a good turnout.
That's excellent.
My name is Irfan.
I am the chef at Baadal,
the Indian restaurant
at the far end of Crittenden.
The one that everyone complains
about because it is so far.
It takes a long bike
ride to get there.
I'm the chef of the
first Indian restaurants.
I cook Indian food as
a fashion and today
is extremely exciting day
for me because today it
seems like the
teacher has come home.
And when the teacher
comes to your doorstep,
it is a day you are ecstatic.
And I'm really, really pleased
to present today's guest.
He was born in Amritsar.
He is a Michelin starred guest.
He is a filmmaker,
a humanitarian,
and the host of "Master
Chef India," which
is a show that's based
on "Master Chef UK."
He has studied in
prestigious institutes
in India, including the Welcome
Groups School of Hotels,
has worked at the Taj group,
the Oberoi, the Leela group.
For those are not
from India, this
is probably strange to you, but
for us who grew up in India,
these were institutions
to be associated with
and he has been in all of them.
He's also studied at the
Culinary Institute of America,
Cornell University, the New York
University, and Le Cordon Bleu.
He's no stranger
to the television.
He was a consultant chef
on Gordon Ramsay's TV
show "Kitchen Nightmares."
He appeared as a judge and
Indian Cuisine Specialist
on the two part season
finale of "Hell's Kitchen."
He appeared on "Throwdown
with Bobby Flay" as a judge.
But if he actually threw
down with Bobby Flay,
I'm sure he would have won.
And he's also been on the India
show the Martha Stewart's show
telecast on March, 2011.
He's hosted the
"Master Chef India"--
two seasons, I believe,
the second season.
Four seasons.
I'm a little behind.
He has authored-- says 13 books,
but I think it's more now.
But "Spice Story
of India," "More
than Indian Cooking,"
"Flavors First," and now
"Return to Rivers."
I am so proud to present
Mr. Vikas Khanna.
Welcome, Vikas.
Please take a seat.
We're going to sit together
like we like each other.
So, Vikas, how have you been?
How have given it in
the Bay Area so far?
Tell us about your
first impression.
VIKAS KHANNA: I'm
a total New Yorker.
No drivers license, no patience,
but everything but the biz.
Because from my hometown I
landed straight in Manhattan.
It's like those movies you've
watched and they got freedom
and they came to America.
It could be after
World War II, but I
think I was fighting a war
with myself to come to U.S.
But, besides that,
it's fantastic.
It doesn't stop snowing
when you're in New York.
We love the pictures, but to
be in the real the pictures,
it's horrible.
and I love the sun here.
And it's thanks to Andrea,
who got me to the West Coast.
And it was on my agenda.
I live in California
for some time.
But it's a great place
because I have so much respect
for all of you because you
all have driver's licenses
and you drive so well.
I can only drive in
my hometown in Amitsar
because I know all the
cops and nobody stops me.
And you can go anywhere.
And It's total freedom, I think.
But besides that
I'm so proud to be--
you're actually the first
few people in America
who are seeing this
book and it's something
about-- there's something
very strange about holding
your book.
Because you see the rough
drafts and you do the sketching.
I wrote this whole book in
Punjabi, my native language,
and then we couldn't
find anywhere
to translate that to English.
I call this book as as
symbol of rebirth for me.
I don't know if I can
ever do this book again.
It's very scary.
Because I remember one
interview I read as a child
for Tanzig-- the
guy who climbed Mt.
Everest.
What was that?
Tenzig.
In Punjabi we call him Tanzig.
So he climbed Mount Everest.
And when he came down
on the ground base,
he was asked, how do you feel.
He said, I feel very sad.
He said, why.
He said, because I will never
find another Everest to climb.
This was the highest peak.
So, in this book I was
holding it first time
when it came to me.
I felt I've touched my
Mount Everest, because it
was about-- I challenged
myself so much in this book.
I wrote this book when I
was totally unemployed.
I have no shame saying
this in America.
I had just closed my third
restaurant and I was on my way
to nowhere.
And here I'm locking the
door of my restaurant
and a call comes from
my friend Tashi saying
that His Holiness, the
Dalai Lama, is in town.
Would you like to meet him?
And my question was why.
I'm just doing a walk
of shame for my life
and this was 2005 end.
So, these things
are not in the book.
So, it's important when I'm
doing something like the book
I tell the something which is
totally true story about what
is behind the glamour
and the real project.
I had no reason to
go to His Holiness,
but I still went there.
I went to Beacon
Theater-- Beacon
Theater it's called
on 73rd Street?
Beacon Theater, and there
were probably 3,000 people.
And wen His Holiness
comes he has
a more impact than President
Obama comes to New York City.
When the president comes
and the streets are blocked,
we all criticize him.
Go back to Washington!
But we never say
that to His Holiness.
And something about that
sacred power of his leadership,
the way he leads us.
I go and meet him.
I still have to pay so
many bills that day.
I didn't care.
I just wanted to see him.
I don't know why.
So, eventually I went
there big face of shame
and everybody asks, oh,
another restaurant closed.
[LAUGHS] You will never
learn how to cook.
I'm like, OK.
And this is the first
person I met right
at the Beacon Theater.
I said, I don't
know why it closed.
It was a big building lawsuit.
Oh, everybody says that.
We have a lease problem.
[LAUGHS]
So I very quietly, humbly
stood last in the line.
And His Holiness
starts walking--
and this is something
which is very
surreal-- it's called surreal.
A double R, I think.
So, I'm walking-- I'm
in the last of the line
and His Holiness comes.
And I don't know what happened.
He's a short man
with a huge presence.
Just humbly bows
and keeps walking.
And he comes and touches
my forehead, like this,
and touches his heart.
And he ha beautiful silk cloth.
Just hands it over to me.
And just goes away as
if nothing happened.
So there's another American
girl standing behind me.
She just pushes me
and says, F-you.
And I'm like, what did I do.
She's saying, oh, you
have Bollywood affect.
I said, I didn't do anything.
I'm like, I didn't even
know what happen to me.
She was so angry at me.
Why didn't it happen to her.
I'm like, I'm sorry,
what happened actually?
So, I didn't know what happened.
But I went to the lecture,
which I was not going to attend.
I just went as a promise
to my friend Tashi.
And I go and sit in the
lecture and His Holiness
sits there so quietly.
And I remember he was
sneezing that day.
And he had this
small handkerchief,
which he would put back
in the clothes he wears.
And he would sneeze like this.
And it was so real.
He's a symbol of something so
high and even he has a cold.
I'm just thinking about that.
And then he talks about that.
You think there's nothing
has end ever in life.
It's always changing
of form and structure.
I think people who
think it's the end,
they're not seeing beyond
what they can achieve.
And I was that one person who
thought it was the end for me.
I go back home in the night.
I called my mom early in
the morning and said, Mom,
I met His Holiness Dalai Lama.
And she says, OK.
I said I'm going to
finish my project.
She said, which project?
I said, "Return to the Rivers."
She said, what is that?
I said, Mom, that's-- this
is a conversation you have
in your native language.
She said, what's that?
I said, it's my book on
Himal-- She's like, oh, no, no,
don't write another book.
Nobody buys your books.
I was like, Oh
mom, that helps me.
She says, remember last
time you wrote a book
and you said you
sold two copies.
I said, yeah, but I bought one,
so I just sold one actually.
She's like, why are you
writing another book?
She's like, isn't that enough
that your restaurant is closed
and you don't have a job.
And I said, Mom,
it's not enough.
It's just not enough.
So she said, where
do you want to go?
I said, I want to go to Bhutan.
And she said, where's that?
I said it's up in the mountains
somewhere in the Himalayas.
So she booked me a ticket
from New York to Bhutan.
And that is when the real
journey started for this book.
I go to Bhutan-- if you
guys know about Bhutan
you must Google-- they
don't have per capita income
or anything like that.
They have per happiness
income, that kind of thing.
I don't know what they call it.
It's something which is
closest to living in paradise.
That place just sucked me in.
I landed, and you have to
land through the valley,
the mountains.
The plane goes like this.
And then the aircraft lands.
It's a palace.
Nobody disturbed nature.
Nothing.
There were stories about
that place which I will never
be able to forget
ever in my life.
So I was totally in
love with that place.
I said this is fantastic
to begin writing
and rediscovered yourself.
All of the lessons what were
in the book started from there.
When I finished
there-- I was there
for almost 2 and 1/2 weeks.
I called my mom.
Can you book me to Tibet?
And she said, where is that.
It's like, come on, ma,
don't ask me these questions.
Just call the agent and book me
a ticket from-- and she said,
oh, this is a very
expensive ticket.
I said, OK.
So I said, then I'm
going to Katmandu.
I don't come from
very huge background.
I figured out, OK,
I'm going to take
a bus from Paro to Katmandu.
It took me three
days, but that was OK.
And not that anything was
happening in my life that time;
it's like nobody needed
me at that point.
And I started traveling by bus.
And I figured out that
the most beautiful stories
happen when you're
not in your comfort
zone, when you're being awake.
There's an American philosopher.
I can't pronounce his name,
so I don't want to insult him.
So He said that when you
look back in your life,
your life will not be
defined about the nights you
slept so well.
They'll be defined by
those sleepless nights.
I can spell his name, but
it was a difficult name.
But I like that,
because all these nights
I was up and thinking what do
I want to do with this book?
The whole project was
about 2,600 pages.
And I finished it in
almost five years.
That time, Junoon was being
born at one time of my life.
In 1990, I read one
article that India
is one of the fastest growing
countries in population.
But it's a shame, we will
never get a Michelin star.
And I said, what
is a Michelin star?
There was no Google-- sorry,
I'm in a Google office.
[LAUGHTER]
VIKAS KHANNA: So you
couldn't Google anything.
So you don't know what
Michelin star was.
But you don't have
much reference
of books at that point.
You know, every time you
read some of my books,
I'll saw we grew up
in a pre-Google age,
where had one newspaper
coming to my hometown.
And there was no
information besides that.
So here you're writing about
such a foreign culture, which
is in between China and India.
And there are so many
beautiful countries
which are dominated by this
whole cultures of Tibet, Nepal,
Bhutan, Burma, North
Pakistan, North India.
I thought this was the
strip I must focus on.
And this is what I continued.
And that's why the book is born.
IRFAN DAMA: What a fascinating
story, seriously fascinating.
But what I love about it is
I love with what humility
you talk about
failures in your life.
You have mentioned of
one of the interviews
that I was seeing that when
you first came to New York,
you literally
started with nothing.
You had $3 in your pocket.
And you ended up at
a homeless shelter.
VIKAS KHANNA: Christmas.
IRFAN DAMA: And you
stayed there for a while.
You got a blanket from someone.
Tell us about the experience.
You had a business
in India, correct?
VIKAS KHANNA: Yes.
IRFAN DAMA: And then
you came to New York.
So my question is what
drew you to New York?
And you were at a
point where-- it
scares most of us
sitting in this room--
to be ever at that situation,
to be in a homeless shelter.
And you came out of that.
So I'd love to know
about that experience.
So it's a touching story.
Please tell us about it.
VIKAS KHANNA: I came to America
in December-- not in December.
My [INAUDIBLE] hit me.
It's on December.
You don't live in calendars.
This is how I had to-- I never
went to proper English schools,
so I think it's my ability.
It's not something
which I should
feel I lack behind something.
Because then I could
figure out my publisher,
she always says that
grammar is not a language.
There's only one language,
and that's the heart.
So I don't worry about grammar.
They'll figure out in a nonce.
I came on December 2 to America.
There's an author in American.
His name is Richard Bach.
Some of us must have
read this book called
"Jonathan Livingston Seagull."
That was the first
book I ever read
by an American author--
my brother gave it
to me-- in which Jonathan
wanted to fly higher.
But where I come from, it was
a very homogeneous structure
of life, where we
only ate a few dishes.
And besides, that
was not our cuisine.
And we will not accept it.
You know, that happens.
But I came to
America-- I don't know,
I think Richard
Bach-- that book,
really-- that 80-page
book was my Bible.
And like a little child
who likes to repeat,
I would keep repeating
reading that again and again.
My brother would say that
maybe you don't understand.
That's why you have to
read it so many times.
I said, it's a very
difficult book, actually.
But how did he figure out to
fly higher than everyone else?
And I don't understand the
story of going back home.
Why did he go back?
And he wanted to teach
everybody to be independent
and to be-- that whole concept
of American individualism.
I was so moved by this.
I said, no, we have
to live in groups,
like in how we live back home.
Everybody has to live
a kind of similar life.
And everybody has to live
almost in that group.
So Jonathan Livingston
Seagull will never be born,
sometimes you feel.
But I wanted to be
somebody who defines
cooking in a different way.
And that is may be one of
the biggest reasons why
I wanted to be at the greatest
stage of cooking of Manhattan.
I don't know, but
maybe that's what
we call destiny,
which we can't define.
But I came here.
And I don't know
if you remember,
if anybody has landed
in New York pre-9/11,
it was a very different country.
9/11 changed so much
of our priorities.
It changed our mindsets.
Even if you look at
the literature written
by American authors before
9/11 and after 9/11,
there's such a
strong subconscious
shift which has happened.
Because I was right there, when
everything started changing.
I was standing right Salaam
Bombay restaurant, just almost
like 1 and 1/2 blocks
away from the site.
I saw that shift.
And that is something
which has really
got me so moved about
the understanding
that this country
is forever evolving.
It is something
which is the spirit
is about-- it's so invincible,
that they reinvent themselves.
And that was something
so important for me.
But before that, I remember
that subway used to cost $1.50.
And I go to a restaurant--
I don't have a cell phone.
Initially, at that point, you
don't have prepaid phones.
You only could get a phone
with a Social Security.
IRFAN DAMA: Right.
VIKAS KHANNA: I never
had a social security,
so like, you know, those
totally-- I can call myself,
yeah, I was illegal
at that time.
I have forgot what was legal.
I said oh, I have a 10-years
visa to come to America.
I'm not illegal.
Sir, it was expired.
IRFAN DAMA: Wow.
VIKAS KHANNA: Your entry was.
And I'm like I had no
idea about those things.
I was just come here
to American to cook.
I didn't have to worry
about all of these things.
We never worried
about these things.
So I didn't have money.
But I only had $3.
So I'm going to the restaurant.
The restaurant is closed.
Nobody informed me.
Nobody called me.
And on Christmas Day, the
restaurants are closed.
So I'm walking up on
Broadway near Canal Street.
And there's a line of people.
And I'm standing in the line.
And a lady comes, and she
hands over to me a blanket.
This is 2000, December 25.
And exactly what I needed.
I needed a blanket that time.
I was shivering.
And my socks were wet.
It had just stop raining.
And she tells me,
Merry Christmas.
I don't know what happened.
I just hugged her.
I said, thank you.
I needed this.
I said what is this line for?
This is the homeless shelter,
New York Rescue Mission.
And now I go to New
York Rescue Mission.
I'm a part of there.
I love everything about
what they stand for.
I think at that
point, you need hope,
more than you need shelter,
more than you need food,
more than you need a blanket.
You need a hope that
it's going to be OK.
It's OK.
God is also saying,
OK, I didn't create you
as a very intelligent creature,
but I'm not repenting it,
because I feel that you will
find your way back home.
And one day, eventually,
you will find your destiny.
All you have to do is
keep your head high.
And I remember when they gave
me shelter to live there too.
And I was so happy to save $3
that I don't have to eat out.
I don't have to try
to take a subway.
And you know, it's OK.
In this country, you can talk
about reinventing and falling
flat on the-- and
I like when Oprah
said it's great to
fall on the ground.
You see the world in a
total new perspective.
It's absolutely true.
And when you have
fallen to the point when
you don't know if you'll
ever get a next meal or not,
or you'll be thrown
out of your apartment,
you have such a different
perspective of success
when you get it.
IRFAN DAMA: That is true.
And they say it's not about
how many times you fall,
it's how quickly you get
up that makes a difference.
But what is really
impressive to see
is you've gone through your
fair share of hardships.
You just mentioned that you
had a third restaurant that
closed down.
And seeing where you are today,
it must have changed you.
VIKAS KHANNA:
There was one thing
which was very
stranger which always
happened to me for a long time.
I'll tell you a small incident.
I used to live in Queens.
And when everybody come, most of
the immigrants live in Queens.
I mean, take Number 7.
That's the best train even now.
It's a favorite train.
So I'm sitting next
to us a sardar-ji,
like a Sikh guy, who's
elderly, like he must be 70s.
So he's asking me, like,
son, what do you do?
I said I make-- you
know, in my culture,
we don't say I make food.
We say [HINDI].
It means "I make bread."
It's such a complex
language, the whole concept
of so many languages
in one country.
So we never say "I cook food."
You always say "I
cook bread" when
you translate it in English.
So I said [HINDI].
He's saying, oh, don't worry.
One day, you'll get a good job.
I said, no!
[LAUGHTER]
VIKAS KHANNA: I said, but
that's all I know how to do.
He's saying, why
don't you drive a cab.
[LAUGHTER]
VIKAS KHANNA: I said, I
don't have driver's license.
He said oh, that's why you cook.
I said--
[LAUGHTER]
VIKAS KHANNA: So he's
saying, oh, no, no.
You are young.
You know, you could do double
shifts in cab and everything.
You can do good money.
I'll put you through.
You look like a decent guy.
And I'm, like, but I
only know how to cook.
He said, oh my god, you're
really dumb, he's telling me.
[LAUGHTER]
VIKAS KHANNA: And then he asked
me, so you have any future?
I said, yeah, I've
been making food.
He said, why, you don't need
any training to make food.
And then he asked me this
very simple question,
which has never left me.
He saw that I was
not moving away
from this concept of that
"I cook bread," literally.
So he's saying, where
did you learn from?
I said, I learned it from
my grandmother's kitchen.
And also, I learned how to
roll a bread at the Golden
Temple, which is like a big
temple in Amritsar, which
is where I was raised.
And he took my
hand and kissed it.
He's saying-- prasaab-dha
means God's food.
He's saying go and
serve God's food.
He's saying, you
continue to do that.
He's saying, you don't have
to drive a cab, don't worry.
[LAUGHTER]
IRFAN DAMA: Wow.
It's interesting.
I guess, hardships change
people in different ways.
Some people, when
they get to success,
they forget about
where they came from.
But obviously, you haven't.
You've set up a number of
humanitarian organizations,
the big one being SAKIV
and Cooking for Life.
So can you tell us something
about these humanitarian
organizations that you have
created, and what's it about?
VIKAS KHANNA: It was after 9/11.
It struck a chord in your
heart in a different way.
You figured out that one thing
which will always sustain us
is togetherness.
And I remember that
I was at the site.
And people were a
little bit-- because I
look so much like my "cousins."
So some people were
getting worried about me,
like what are you
doing on this site?
And it was fear is a
very dangerous thing.
It is not hatred.
Hatred is a very
small part of fear.
What are you doing here?
And I'm, like, I want to help.
So the restaurant was
right across the street
from the site.
So every single day--
initially nobody
would come-- but every single
day, outside the restaurant
Salaam Bombay, I'll put a
small buffet for all the people
who are volunteering
at the site.
I will make one
biriyani, one dhal,
and I'll have some fresh breads.
Because nobody was
coming to the restaurant.
After that, that area just died.
Tribeca started
crumbling, because nobody
wanted to take it as
a tourist destination.
You don't want to go--
and people would tell me
we don't want to go out and eat.
I would tell my
friends, please, come in
and support my restaurant.
And they will say, I don't
want to eat near a graveyard.
And that would be,
like, oh my god,
would I ever get out of this?
It was, like,
something which was
so scary for an immigrant
who was brown at that point,
standing right on the site, who
wanted to be of some support
to even one soul at that point.
And at that same point, we
had some riots in Queens.
And a lot of Sikhs
were-- there was
a bit assault and everything.
And that is, again, pre-Google.
And we don't have those images.
Right now, we can get images
of what is a "lunger."
"Lunger" is a
community kitchen which
comes from the
Sikh temples, where
the whole institution
of Sikhism is
based on that everyone is equal.
There's no sense of division
of societies in them.
So when you look
at lunger, where
I learned how to cook-- so
I drew a painting of a Sikh
who was serving a little
child, a beggar child.
I don't know I was
imagining myself as a child
or I was imagining myself
as-- So I drew a sketch,
and I stood on the site.
And I kept telling people,
you know, these are Sikhs.
They are different.
These are the people
who actually raised me.
And there was one
professor from NYU.
He asked me saying,
why're you doing this?
I said, even if I could tell one
person the story of who we are.
Everybody has to
tell their own story.
And he said continue to do this.
This is the conviction which
will make you stand out
in the United States of America,
that I saw you standing there
for two hours.
No one spoke to you.
You were invisible.
IRFAN DAMA: Wow.
VIKAS KHANNA: He's saying
you're invisible right now.
But as long as you believe
it, you will become visible.
So this plaque what you're
holding it, don't forget it.
This is something which
is representing you
and York City and your people.
Don't forget it.
And I remember that was a
very important somebody patted
on her back, on like that
women who gave me blanket.
It was a similar kind
of moment for me.
When I said that it is very
important if you believe
in something, you've
got to stand up.
If you need to be counted,
you need to stand up.
And that is something
which I learned
because I was born with a very
strange physical disability,
in which I never played
throughout my childhood.
So I have no memory of
me playing at as a child.
I had club feet, which is a very
common problem in First World
countries, but in my part of
the world, that's a big problem.
Your feet are inside,
you're a ghost.
"But Mummy, I'm a ghost."
That's what everybody
in the class tells me.
But you learned how to stood up.
And that is what I felt that it
is very important that what you
do is it cannot come
from anywhere else.
The source has to be within you.
And I know, being a chef--
some people tell me.
Just go care, who cares
what you're saying?
No, it's important.
It's important that I
share in what I believe in.
Because what'll happen that this
all of these stories add up.
And they become a small
epic of our own life.
And that is what
my mom taught me.
She's saying if somebody
says that you're
a ghost, tell them
thank you, angel.
IRFAN DAMA: Wow.
VIKAS KHANNA: And I did that.
I said, oh yeah.
So the foundations
all of us started
based on that there was an
equal amount of awareness.
There was some things I did with
the Egyptian government right
before they collapsed.
And I wanted to have more
accessibility on the World
Wonders.
Now, you would say
why would you do that?
Yeah, I figured out that
it was difficult for me
to access some blessed places.
So SAKIV was so much
based on creating events.
We did events at the
pyramids, at the Taj Mahal.
I want planning a
next one in Brazil.
Maybe collect chefs and they
all put the energy and food
into it.
You create awareness of events.
It's important.
IRFAN DAMA: Mmm-hmm.
I agree.
Not to forget
where we come from.
I want to spend some time
talking about your book.
You've told us how long
you took to write the book.
It's a big work in progress.
But the most interesting thing--
there are a couple of things.
I glanced through your book.
And we spoke about
it over lunch.
I hope you enjoyed
lunch, by the way.
VIKAS KHANNA: Yes, great.
IRFAN DAMA: It's a
big honor to have
Vikas eating at my restaurant.
That's so awesome.
Google's restaurant,
I just [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
IRFAN DAMA: FYI.
[HINDI]
VIKAS KHANNA: We take everything
what we're successful.
All successful things are ours.
IRFAN DAMA: But the one thing
that I loved about the book
is you started with the
Buddhist mealtime prayer.
And how do people in the
Himalayan River Valley--
how do they view their
meals and the food they eat?
And how is it so
different from what
the Americans do and
their approach to food.
VIKAS KHANNA: See, I
find it very difficult
to compare two cultures.
I have always had
this problem of living
in two different countries.
But one thing which I
love about appreciation
of, when people have such
a high regard of, sharing.
And there's a Buddhist
meal time prayer.
And the book starts with,
saying that every grain is
a the sacrifice of life.
May I be worthy
of that sacrifice.
May my unwholesome
qualities turn
to wholesome qualities
when I consume this life.
I thought that was
something so beautiful,
because even if you're
consuming rice, that has life.
It has the potential tomorrow
to fight against the gravity
and rise to the sun
and create a new crop.
That is sexy!
[LAUGHTER]
IRFAN DAMA: That is true.
VIKAS KHANNA: When we look
at the magic of soil--
we saw the movie "Vaali."
And I was so affected
by "Vaali" that it
is all about that
little sprout which
defines our existence
on the planet.
And that Buddhist
meal time prayer
made me feel about
the little grain,
that we are all-- the
day that we don't see it,
we are all struggling for
that little sprout, which
we don't even think is
so And in this prayer,
they made that sprout as
the center of the universe.
IRFAN DAMA: Wow.
VIKAS KHANNA: So I was
I said the book has
to start from that kind of note.
And how Americans
eat differently.
What Americans can do, the
rest of the world can do.
We could create Google.
The world just follows.
I was Googling
Google headquarters
and doesn't Google Maps before
coming to the Google office.
How can you Google
more than that?
[LAUGHTER]
IRFAN DAMA: Exactly.
VIKAS KHANNA: I'm like
are you serious, man?
As you know, one
thing we also have
to understand that America
is a reflection of the world.
We see traces of the whole
world in the American hope
or American dream.
It's like there's something
so powerful when you have,
when you meet American
kids who are--
and I feel proud
every day to be part
of that cycle in
some way at least.
Even if I'm in the
kitchen in Junoon.
And I'm feeding that creativity
of the American mind.
This book-- on this
high commission
could be produced in America,
because of the American--
that curiosity to know more.
And in this book I
said there are so
many places where lot
of people will not
be able to travel to Mustang,
which is northeast of Nepal,
where Nepal people
have not gone.
And it's like, it's so many
difficult places that where
I went to.
And I said where
people can't travel,
I'm doing a small
thing of bringing
that small piece of land of
Himalayas to their Kitchens
through this book.
So when you look at the American
creativity of thought process,
that is something
which is so different.
The way Americans think,
they way they write,
the way they approach
in a very global way.
That is something
which we all gravitate,
and we aspire from it.
I could have never thought this
as a very important project
if I was living in Amritsar.
IRFAN DAMA: Right.
VIKAS KHANNA: I possibly
would've never taught
that Himalayas could be
something so large and massive
and splendor of the food and
the culture and the people.
Till you came to America
and you figured out
that it's so important.
IRFAN DAMA: I glanced
through the book.
The book truly
excited me-- mostly.
[HINDI] I'm going to
get you to sign it.
No, I got this.
But I read through this.
And a lot of the recipes
really fascinated me.
And I'm definitely going to use
these recipes in my restaurant.
I'm going to have
a Vikas Khanna Day.
I love so many--
the simplicity is
what touched me-- the
simple mustard greens.
They're such incredibly
simple dishes,
but the one thing--
and I told you
I was going to ask you this
question-- is about the 108
caves of meditation potatoes.
VIKAS KHANNA: Yeah, yeah.
It's a very interesting place.
It's near Llasa.
It's approximately three hours
drive from Llasa in Tibet.
And I went to Tibet
because-- we all
go to Tibet because
we love His Holiness.
It's something
about Potala Palace,
which is the-- and Potala is
fantastic, if anybody has not
Googled it, must Google it.
It had a red side
and the white side.
Right side is the Parliament
or the political side.
So he says the white side
is a spirituality side.
So he says that both teams
have been balanced in sync.
And it is like approximately
three hours from there.
There is a place where they
have 108 caves on the mountains.
So I decided one day I'm going
to go to all those 118 caves.
And on the way, they
had these two things
which were fantastic.
One is they served
these potatoes, which
are boiled potatoes, and
they come in a plastic bag
and with chopsticks.
And you keep feeding
that starch as you
travel through these mountains.
And there was a second
thing which was so shocking.
It's a true example
of our existence
that how we define our
cuisines and how we actually
continue to live and thrive.
VIKAS KHANNA: They had
made a small kind of a-- it
looked like a soap-- a batch
of potato starch, which
was boiled, and made
into this small block.
It was sitting there.
And it's noodles actually.
So I'm like OK, but
where are the noodles.
And the woman is, like,
could you be little patient?
But where are the noodles?
This is just a block.
You cut it.
What do you do with it?
So they have this small kind
of a piece of a-- like a lid.
You know the lids which come out
of the tuna box and everything
So that kind of little
finger handle, and then
she had made holes in it.
So what she would do that
she wants to slide over
that little block of
potato starch block,
and the noodles will come out.
It's in the book.
And I'm looking at
this, and I was, like,
wow, that is fantastic.
So what she does is
that she makes them
and then she tosses with a
little bit of garlic chili
oil and all those things.
But one thing which I also
found very interesting
is-- I'm not going
against China.
Please nobody quote
that-- but I found
a pasta making machine which
is more than 1,000 years old
in northwest of Bhutan.
And I'm going to show
you a picture of that.
And it is like a
huge lemon press,
like the lemon press
we have to squeeze
lemon juice or the garlic press?
They had this kind
of wooden thing.
Now, this is that potato
noodles with chili paste.
This is how she figured
out that there's
a big block of potato
starch thing which
was potato starch
just cooked in water
and which was quite
like thick like gelatin.
It's very much like jelly.
And then she scraps it
with this little thing.
And this is what comes out.
IRFAN DAMA: Wow.
VIKAS KHANNA: And I was like,
this is a beautiful story.
So the whole book
when it was created,
it was almost 2,600
pages of research.
The whole book would've
gone-- but then
it will become very
unuser-friendly, and cost
effective.
Shipping will be a problem.
IRFAN DAMA: Exactly.
I can tell you right
now, I can't serve that.
To make that for 1,000 bowls,
I think my hand will fall off.
[LAUGHTER]
VIKAS KHANNA: You know, practice
is what makes them so fast.
One scrape, and bowl is ready.
How fast she was.
And there's one
more thing which I
want to say about the
dedication page of this book.
This book is dedicated to
this woman whom I don't know,
and I will never possibly
be able to meet her again.
I'm quite forgetful,
and I know that.
So I had this small computer
VAIO, that black one,
the cheapest one I used to have.
So I had everything
documented there,
and this is the last
stop, 108 caves.
So there was a
small place, which
was like last time I'm
going to have butter tea.
So I wanted to have my last
butter tea in total peace.
And then we had a small
van-- like the Maruti van
which used to come in India.
It's a 10-seater van.
My driver is like run, run, run!
So I ran out, and I forgot
my laptop in the bag next
to my chair.
And I forgot, and
I'm totally excited.
And now I'm getting carried
away with the new sights
and everything.
I still had my little camera.
I took all this pictures myself.
So I'm clicking more images.
And suddenly, the bus stopped.
There was a Tibetan woman
from the top of the hill.
She ran down the slope to
give my computer back to me.
IRFAN DAMA: Wow.
Incredible.
VIKAS KHANNA: And I'm trying to
give her something, because I
don't know how to react to this.
Like nobody has done this
kind of running for me.
So she shrugged, and she
said something in Tibetan.
I asked the driver.
She said that anyone
would have done that.
IRFAN DAMA: Wow.
VIKAS KHANNA: And she must
have that ran about two miles,
more than that.
And that sight never leaves me.
You know, the married women
wear apron-looking dresses,
and they are so beautiful.
She must be in her 60s, but
her running down that hill
and giving me the computer is
why this book is born today.
I would have lost almost all my
data, everything, all images.
And more than that, I would
have lost hope that I can do it.
And that hope led
to another hope,
and that led to another
hope, which got me here.
IRFAN DAMA: That is incredible.
I have to tell you I
spent two years in Delhi,
when I worked at the
[INAUDIBLE] Sheraton.
And that was when I was
first introduced to momos.
I'd never heard about
momos before that.
There was a small little
restaurant in chana ke puri,
where all the [INAUDIBLE]
students used to go.
And they would have momos.
And I think the first
time, I had a thing--
it had 60 momos or something.
It was so good.
So you have covered momos to
great degree in this book.
Give us something real
quick about momos.
It's such an incredible dish.
VIKAS KHANNA: You know, momos
is a very interesting dough.
It's a very interesting dough.
It's just flour, salt and water.
And then use your instinct.
It needs to be a firm dough,
because if you let it rest,
cover with a wet cloth
for half an hour.
That's all you need.
But lot of people when
I was doing any classes
or doing my training of my
own chefs in the restaurant,
we were worried about
the shape of the momos,
you know that intricate
shape, in which we
do touch a lot of that
shapes in his book.
But one thing was which
is-- I tell them, tell
people who cares
how the shape is.
But the beauty of momos
is that you can stuff them
with anything you have, any
leftovers, any restaurant
food which is left.
It needs to be dry for sure.
And if you have
minced meat, just
add some salt and
lemon juice to it.
You could just stuff that in.
Steaming is a great
healthy way to eat.
But one more thing,
which I figured out,
that you could actually
make momos with whole wheat
flour too.
And you can use a
lot of greens too.
And this is one of my
favorite test stories about.
I go to this woman's house.
This is in Paro.
It's the capital of Bhutan.
This is actually the
only city in the world
where there's no traffic lights.
I think there's
one traffic signal
in Bhutan, the whole
of the country.
And nobody breaks traffic rules!
When I got my driver's
license-- again,
I come back to driving-- in
Bhutan, they drive so well.
They have so much
respect for nature.
They don't honk.
They don't do anything.
I don't know.
It's a totally different
thought process,
in which they say,
we don't honk,
not to disturb the
other driver, but we
don't honk to
disturb the nature.
IRFAN DAMA: Wow.
VIKAS KHANNA: So
I was like, wow.
So this woman has this, and she
is making me the butter tea.
If you've ever seen
this movie called
"Seven years in Tibet,
with Brad Pitt,"
the last line of the movie
is that "Butter tea was never
my cup of tea."
This is a tea, which is made
with tea, little bit of milk,
water, lots of yak
butter, and salt.
I know it doesn't
sounds delicious at all.
It is not.
[LAUGHTER]
VIKAS KHANNA:
First sip, you will
say I can't be having this
floating grease in my mouth,
like are you serious?
But you went to anyone's
house, it was there.
So I write about this that I got
so upset with this butter tea.
So in my little
apartment in Manhattan
which is the size of a matchbox,
it only smelled of butter tea.
So anyone who'd come to
visit me, I'll [INAUDIBLE].
And people are,
like, are you weird?
We're never coming
back to your house
again if this is the next time
you're going to do this to us.
But this woman, had this
kind of a stirrer, a whisk,
which is from a tree.
So I asked her can I have that?
She said you can have anything,
but you can't have this.
It was given to me
by my mother-in-law.
I said OK.
So I loved that.
A whisk I could not buy.
But I wanted to take a picture
of it to put in the book
and say, eventually,
when I was walking out,
her daughter gave it
to me, because she
saw that my heart was like
oh my god, that's a whisk?
It looked exactly like a whisk.
It's a top of a tree.
And they use that to make tea.
I thought this is really great.
And I thought, that organicness
is something which connects us
all to something which is
very pure, that simplicity.
IRFAN DAMA: That is
very, very incredible.
I have to ask you that
incredible story you told us
in 2005 when the Dalai
Lama touched your forehead.
And then, you now have him
writing the forward in "Return
to the Rivers."
How did that
happen-- you managed
to get him writing
for your book.
That's incredible.
Tell us about it.
VIKAS KHANNA: Destiny?
Pure destiny.
I always feel that
there was something
so honest in what I was doing,
when I was writing this.
I was not worried about if my
next meal is going to come,
what is going to
happen to my life.
It's like what am I doing?
But there was something in the
universe which was constantly
guiding me and telling me you
are doing the right thing, son.
And it was something
is telling me
that I choose people
to do projects,
like there was a
bigger power telling me
that you didn't
choose this project.
I chose you to do this project.
And when I met his Holiness,
he was asking me questions.
He was literally
trying to test me.
So I went for
meditation with him.
And Kalachakra is the
biggest Buddhist congregation
which happens in Bodh Gaya.
Bodh Gaya is a place in India
where Buddha was enlightened.
So at Kalachakra, we
have lot of people.
And I thought I will never
get to be sitting with him,
because Richard Gere's there,
and everybody from Hollywood
there.
And [INAUDIBLE] looking at me.
Basically, he pulls me on.
And he starts talking
to me about the project.
I'm, like, really?
And then there was
another guy who
was there, who was
complaining nonstop.
Oh you don't know, I
have so much money.
But I don't understand
why my kids left me,
my wife is getting married
and she didn't inform me.
And my [INAUDIBLE] that at
him, and say "my friend,
you need scotch."
[LAUGHTER]
VIKAS KHANNA: Stop
complaining, he tells that way.
He does!
You think, you
started this intent
through saying that
you are so rich.
Stop feeling bad about yourself.
Stop feeling bad.
On top of that,
you're telling me
how poor you are because
you can't connect to anyone?
And I'm like oh my God, look
at his presence of mind.
And then he tells me--
immediately, looks at you, says
did you go to-- I said, yes.
I went to Amdo.
Bundle is his birthplace.
I knew it somehow that he's
going to ask me that question.
I don't know why.
And I said I learned how to
make your favorite bread there.
It's "Amdo Bread" in the book.
And he just kept
holding my hand.
And that guy kept
complaining in the behind.
Like, but what do you want
me to do it with my life?
You know, I have so much money.
He does this to
get him to shut up.
But he wanted to hear
the story of bread,
which is his childhood bread.
He goes back to Dharamshala
and within almost three weeks,
I get a letter from his
office, about congratulating me
of accomplishing this project.
And that's the forward.
IRFAN DAMA: Incredible.
I don't know how many
people in the world
would be able to have this.
I am so impressed.
I've got to ask you one last
question as a chef looking
to you.
You have accomplished so much.
It's so much.
I mean, we could never
dream of accomplishing
13 books and so
many appearances.
But you don't take time to rest.
Is there going to be time
for life any time soon.
Is there going to be
a Mrs. Vikas Khanna?
[LAUGHTER]
IRFAN DAMA: Someday, are
you going to take a break
and just say time to enjoy
what I have accomplished?
VIKAS KHANNA: I feel that
this platform is fantastic.
I went to launch
this book in India.
I wanted my motherland
to see this book first.
I don't know what--
I'm not that patriotic.
I take it is as I feel.
So Jaipur Lit Festival is
the largest literary festival
in India, where
Oprah went last year
and then before that, Deepak
Chopra's spoken there.
Salman Rushdie was not
allowed to speak there,
but I was allowed.
IRFAN DAMA: Good on you!
Good on you!
Excellent.
VIKAS KHANNA: So they never
had a chef there before,
Jaipur Lit Festival.
They never had a
cookbook launch there.
It's the largest South
Asian literary festival,
and I'm just going there.
And I'm a little
worried because I
know there's going
to be a lot of press.
So I'm asking the
people at the festival,
do you rent people just
to fill up my place?
I don't want to be
standing there alone,
that, OK, I came all the way
from America to open this book.
So all throughout, I'm asking
people, so can you come?
They say, yeah, we'll come.
It's like I can pay you guys.
I'm thinking I should
have 100 rupees notes
and I would give it to everyone.
Please come for this.
So I go there,
there's a Bollywood
director who's talking there.
So he has almost like
100 people there.
So I'm like can we
tell these people that
after this that--
he thinks chef,
can you be a little
less paranoid?
You're scaring us.
You know what, it's
going to such an insult,
like, here I'm talking
that I don't want
to open this book
in America first.
I want to open this
book in India first.
And I call my mom.
And she's like no,
I'm not interested.
[LAUGHTER]
VIKAS KHANNA: I thought nobody's
ready to come to my book
lecture.
And they said we put you
in the Google Mughal tent.
I said I don't know
what that means,
that people have
to Google my tent?
So there's a place in
Jaipur Lit Festival.
it's called Google Mughal Tent.
And they said chef, please,
we don't want your anxiety
going all over the place.
We have people waiting here
since last night in the tent.
IRFAN DAMA: Wow.
VIKAS KHANNA: I went there.
They were more than
3,000 people waiting
to see this book being
opened in front of them.
IRFAN DAMA: Incredible.
VIKAS KHANNA: So I felt that
was my bigger accomplishment
than having a life
partner or having
anything else in my life.
I hold this book
like this, and I
could hear people
yelling and crying.
I said this is symbol of home.
As I told, I'm there, and
I looked at all this kids.
And then it was difficult for
me to get out of the crowd,
because I disturbed that
whole festival for that day.
I know that.
Because I went up and
told them the story of why
I came back home,
because I said,
because in my favorite
book, Jonathan Livingston
comes back home.
I wanted to go back home
and see how the home was.
IRFAN DAMA: Wonderful.
Well, just by saying that
you've no time for a life
or a wife-- the
sexiest chef around.
I don't know how many hearts
are broken in the audience.
But truly, an incredible story.
You know, how you can tell you
that you talked to a real chef?
This is from a tandoor.
His hands are
really, really worn.
These scarred hands.
VIKAS KHANNA: You never
need to go for waxing.
Everything is
burned, everything.
You never need to ever for it.
If everybody wants to go
get a nice free waxing, say,
can I put my hand
in the tandoor?
So you get perfect clean waxing.
People ask me, so you wax?
I said, no.
Oh but you have
you're waxed one hand.
IRFAN DAMA: Tandoor.
And what an incredible story.
I'm now going to open to
questions in the audience.
Does anybody have any
questions for Vikas?
Vinod here will hand
you the microphone,
so if you have a question,
please raise your hand
and Vinod will come over
and give you the microphone.
AUDIENCE: Before 2005
and after, would you say
was that anything that
different than you
did, that you know
what you wanted
and everything like
a lot of success.
What was the difference
before and after?
VIKAS KHANNA: The biggest
difference, I felt,
was that there was a time
when the transitional time
of Indian cuisine, I would
say, from their reference,
that a lot of people, a lot
of friends, we would meet,
who were totally in not very
approval of Indian cuisine.
"I hate curry."
Like, you know, I heard
that word many times.
But after that, I was convinced.
I would patronize the
cuisine, not the people.
If you patronize
something which is art,
it is much bigger
than the people.
I think that is
what I was convinced
in 2005, when I'd
failed so many times.
Because somebody would say
"change this," and I'll run.
I'll change it, because I
wanted to patronize everyone.
In the middle of this
whole transition,
I forgot that I would
rather be a slave to art
than to be to people.
For me, the culture was the art.
The food was the art.
I just focused on
that after that.
I just stopped worrying
about-- even now,
when something has to be
done the right way, we do it.
And I feel that people
respond more to that,
than if you just keep
changing for everyone's
individual perception.
And yeah, I didn't
go to great schools.
Initially, cooking was
the only thing I did.
But one thing I figured out
you focus only on something
you're convinced about.
Rest is not important.
Rest comes as a very
important by-product.
I don't know if anything
made sense what I said.
AUDIENCE: OMG.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I'm a big fan.
I actually have started
my own food page.
And I'm up every day,
visitor of your page.
And that's when I came to
know that you'll be in Google,
so I somehow tracked
down my friend
that I really want to
come to the campus.
And I really wanted
to come and see you.
One question.
I've sent you many messages
on Facebook, but haven't--
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: --had
any response yet.
IRFAN DAMA: [INAUDIBLE]
that pressure.
AUDIENCE: I sent you
a link of my page.
Hey, what do you
think about my page?
It's a food blog.
No, no response.
AUDIENCE: Awww.
IRFAN DAMA: See, this
is why you should
be married, because
my wife answers
all my Facebook questions.
[LAUGHTER]
IRFAN DAMA: And she's
always on top of things.
She's my publicist, so.
VIKAS KHANNA: Hi.
[LAUGHTER]
VIKAS KHANNA: I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: Send again?
VIKAS KHANNA: I'm not the
greatest person to click.
My lady who does my--
AUDIENCE: You should
blame the publicist.
VIKAS KHANNA: Publicist.
[INAUDIBLE] here.
I'm just writing
a big encyclopedia
of festive foods of India.
And I start this journey
from Indus Valley,
what festivals they
must be celebrating,
and what foods they
must be eating.
In Greek, Greek people or
Greeks, like what language,
they say that artist
dies, art lives.
I'm a [INAUDIBLE]
believer of that.
Right now, and I'm
that story of Mirabai
which we hold in the mythology,
who fell in love with Krishna.
And she couldn't
see anything else.
She could even have
consumed poison.
But the love was so much
greater for something else.
So what has happened
that I do have
a lot of people who does
my social media, also.
But I am the one who says
that today God has given me
a voice, after being mute
and dumb for so many years.
At this time, I must
discover more art.
So in this space and time, I
will never become a shopkeeper,
like I will never have
pickles coming out of my name
with a smile.
Nothing.
I'm the slave of art.
And that is what
all my energy goes.
And I've apologized
in the middle of this
if I'm ignoring something.
AUDIENCE: You're not.
VIKAS KHANNA: I'm
not, but I just
feel that there's something
that-- how many people give
an opportunity given that I
live in India and America both.
In America, they don't
know that I live in India.
And in India, they don't
know I live in America.
So I think this whole confusion
of time lapse, my whole life
is like in different space.
AUDIENCE: No, we have full
tab on when you're in America
and when you're in India.
[LAUGHTER]
IRFAN DAMA: Wonderful.
VIKAS KHANNA: Can I cook
for you to apologize?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Yes, do, yes.
IRFAN DAMA: Wow.
AUDIENCE: Can you
get jimbu here?
You mentioned it's such
a great alternative
to cumin-based tempering.
Jumbu, as we call
in Uttarakhand.
VIKAS KHANNA: Oh my
god, where are you from?
AUDIENCE: Uttarakhand
which is Kumaun, and--
VIKAS KHANNA: Wowwwww!
I paid my money, he says right.
Somebody I figured
out I was right.
AUDIENCE: So I think what
is there is quite authentic.
Like, I think it's gone to
Nepal as well as Uttarakhand.
So can you get it?
Right now, my only way
is to smuggle it through,
like get it from
India basically.
VIKAS KHANNA: Yeah.
That's what I suggest too.
IRFAN DAMA: Smuggle it.
VIKAS KHANNA: Smuggle it.
Hey, you know, every
time I'm coming back,
and I'm at the airport.
And I'm just getting
into the Customs,
and the guy says, you're the
same guy from Gordon Ramsay,
right?
I said, yeah.
Are you getting in some spices?
I said yes.
He said OK, go.
IRFAN DAMA: Wow!
VIKAS KHANNA: But the only thing
I do is I steal and I bring.
Anybody recording, also?
It's OK.
IRFAN DAMA: It's OK.
VIKAS KHANNA: Love is love.
But jimbu is a very
unique herb, which
is used in Uttarakhand
cuisine and it's
used in Nepalese cuisine.
One thing which is unique
is that it is so delicate
that what you do is
that you heat the oil,
not totally burn it.
You add jimbo.
Instantly, you add
it over lentils.
It's such a fragrant,
holistic smell.
It's only used in lentils,
in Uttarakhand and in Nepal.
But if you would ever
make a journey to Mustang,
in northeast of Nepal, where
they-- you must Google this.
Google is free for
you guys anyway.
[LAUGHTER]
VIKAS KHANNA: Mustang,
this is the place
where they found about 1,500
years old caves of Buddha.
They use jimbu in making
meat and in preserving meat.
I was like wow!
How do I smuggle this.
But you're right.
Some things are very
difficult when you talk about
substitutions, , because
you don't want to destroy
the beauty of it.
So I put the jimbu--
call it jimbu.
A lot of people say,
it's not "Hi- MAL-yan,"
it's "hi ma LAY an."
I said no!
It's a Sanskrit word.
At least for one time in my
life, I'm right [INAUDIBLE].
IRFAN DAMA: All right.
Well, thank you
everyone for coming.
And Vikas--
VIKAS KHANNA: Likewise.
IRFAN DAMA: Thank you
so much for coming here.